[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh mike chirico
doing big boy stuff he's uh hosting the
olympics prime time a host you can catch
him with the olympic coverage in prime
time at eight eastern on nbc
mike joins us now are you keeping up on
other sports there mike
very little but i did put my hand in the
air for nick foles when you mention nick
okay now is that a real backdrop
behind you or is that something that you
manufactured mike
wait a minute i'll throw something
through the open window and it'll go
into the water watch
okay uh see the splash i
i no i i i don't think i did
i i need to tell you that it's not it's
not a real okay i need to
it's it's the middle of the night here
it's 10 25 i'm staying up for you guys i
have to be up in six hours
uh i have to tell you something though
uh there's a show on peacock
with uh carrie champion and kenny mayne
and i'm on their show a half hour before
we go on nbc
and we do a crosstalk and i have no idea
what's coming up
and we started talking and randomly
kenny
brought up gary miller and
the world cup and i just started
laughing uncontrollably
that would be just soccer and breakdown
soccer breakdown actually that's what
kenny said kenny said
at some point in our conversation but
yeah you know this is a good event
and i think the us may win a medal in
that kenny said soccer breakdown in
three two one
and i just absolutely lost it
and the listeners may not get it but at
least i can share that with you
soccer breakdown in three two
party three two one fifa soccer's three
the red card has become the calling card
for this year's tournament
seven objections for three
two one witness romania's ian bladio
against the swiss is ort through
three two one cameroon
we we always have it ready mike oh
i i i cried and our group and you know
some of them ron vaccaro our research
group is sitting there
and i started to explain to the guys
like guys you don't understand
if this video if i hear this audio
i truly tear up i i can't stop laughing
hey kenny said that in the middle of the
interview and i was done it was great it
was fast
just for context gary miller at espn was
voicing over
in the 90s a world cup and he knows
nothing about soccer obviously as you
could tell
and then there's the tough
pronunciations so we're listening to
this
we're at work and we're just we're
eavesdropping on gary miller trying to
uh
you know not butcher these names and i
at one point i opened the door of the uh
the booth you know and he goes get out
and and i just because it was crushing
us he was so
so funny it's so funny oh my gosh he
he made me laugh as much as anyone that
group
the one thing about that group of all of
us and i was a little bit late to the
group but
you know me ravaged linda cohen on the
back end of that group and you're there
and gary and obviously
uh charlie steiner and robin roberts and
bob lee are doing the six o'clock sports
center back in the day
the one thing about that group is that
group had all had the ability to laugh
at themselves and that is actually what
got us through
a lot of those times and you think back
it's 30 years later and
you still smile and laughing you bring
up one anecdote
it's a great time in all of our lives it
really was
do you have tough names to pronounce
like
do you get tripped up yeah the
the olympics are so hard because there's
not even a frame of reference where
you've heard the names before
uh the internationally you know that you
spend probably
more time working on that and the
research team uh
this is not just like a check the box
say they're amazing
how do you say the name of the runner
from
oh it's hang on a second we'll get the
and they get it right
and they make sure you they do the best
they can to make sure you get it right
uh you know i i i think i learned with
when i started doing the olympics and
those around you
and al michaels you can't prepare for
the entirety of the olympics
it's impossible there are 11 000
athletes you're never going to know them
uh it's not like there's a reservoir of
knowledge so you just try to take bits
and pieces know the key athletes
but if you're going to jump in and do a
greco-roman wrestling highlight because
there was
a protest there was an emotional finish
there was controversy
you're going to get a couple of those
names so you try to do the best you can
with them out of respect for these
athletes because
they are all pretty incredible in their
own way we're talking to mike tarico
joining us
from tokyo and you'll see him tonight
prime time
at eight eastern on nbc the approach of
we know what happened to you coming on
prime time
to then say basically you know what
happened or
do you play it sort of we're not quite
sure what happened
down the road we'll show you how uh
terry gannon and the gymnastics team
called it
right uh you play it like that without
giving away the result
because there are still people and there
were a couple of people who were
mad at me last week when simone biles
uh withdrew during the competition and i
said undoubtedly you know that simone
bile's withdrew because it was the top
story on the nightly news with lester
and it was top story on cbs's news and
everywhere
right and it was 20 hours old so we
intentionally said that but didn't say
the result of the competition
in case anyone wanted to do that i think
the spoiler alert days are kind of done
with the amount of information out there
and video and phones
and the 13-hour time difference these
are still the biggest events and people
are going to want
want to watch simone biles compete uh
the competition that just ended up this
morning u.s
time that they're gonna want to watch
that tonight as a matter of fact the
only reason i'm dressed this nice
is because i truly just came downstairs
i interviewed simone
uh for about 15 minutes and that'll be
on the prime time show
uh tomorrow tonight i should say u.s
time
but we're not going to pretend like
people don't know that she competed and
she competed
most people are going to know she won a
bronze medal but we're not going to
stand there and flag wave and say
hey guess what you can watch and see
what happens we'll show you how that
played out just trying to be as honest
as possible while respecting those who
do want to see what happened
what did you learn from simone after
interviewing her
wait dan she was really uh more
talkative than i thought she was going
to be
to be quite honest uh i want i'd love to
go back and listen to
uh some of her answers even more closely
uh she talked about
how the the mental part of this was real
how she had to get cleared by doctors to
go back out and
compete again uh she has been through
this before but
not anything like this where she would
just get lost in the air
uh all of those things were were pretty
fascinating and uh
she is um she was really proud of
winning a bronze medal she wanted a
bronze in the beam last year in the same
event that she wanted to bronze it a few
hours ago
she's won seven of medals that's the
most for any american
gymnast all time and she said she is as
proud of this one
if not prouder of this one than any of
the seven because of what she's been
through the last couple of weeks
did she talk about retiring yeah
i know that's one of those questions
like she just got done competing she's
gonna give you an answer
she she did she did leave the door open
for paris i'll say that
um which i think it's only fair at this
point
you have to unpack so much usually these
gymnasts like to go on a tour
afterwards it's their opportunity to get
some financial success out of their
olympic success
so i wouldn't be surprised if that
happens but she did not slam the door
and her coaches who have helped her
through this phase are
french and there's a part of her that
has said maybe it won't be in the
all-around but she
would love to try to hang around and do
one apparatus perhaps
so she didn't slam the door and say i'm
done finished but
it's so soon after i would not hold her
to whatever answer she gave on that
what a bonus to have michael phelps on
set where you think you're going to
use him for swimming and then you're
using him for mental health with
simone biles and i thought he was
wonderful
yeah i'm glad you said that dan he was a
stud he was just
awesome he was honest uh you've talked
to him about that
he's that weight of gold series
or uh documentary i should say that they
did on hbo was just
um excellent and she shed so much light
that
i think i had an idea about but didn't
really know until i heard the raw
stories of many athletes
involved and then you know michael
wanted his first answer when i asked him
about the simone bios thing was
i wish we had an hour to talk about this
right so as soon as we got done
i asked our folks that hey can we talk
to michael and just put it on peacock or
and he was up for it so we did i think
about 26 27 minutes
that was just posted in the last couple
of days it is very very very little to
do with me
it's just kind of giving michael a forum
to speak about it and he's
honest about it and he he pointed this
out dan which i know you've
seen and you've experienced firsthand
that when these athletes get done with
the olympics
it's over man it just stops but they've
built for foreign in the cases of these
athletes
five years for this week for their
moment for you know i just watched 200
meters it's
20 seconds that's it done and now
what am i training for you know katie
ledecky in the pool every day
not going to get in the pool for a while
so it's eye opening
and uh michael helped share with us what
a lot of these athletes are going to be
going through around the world as they
go back home this week
and i don't know if you know the impact
that you and phelps had
and helped simone biles because
michael's the greatest ever
and and he went through this so he's
saying hey this is
real and i think it helped instead of
because simone was
on twitter people people roughed her up
and yeah but then you had people who
backed her i mean like it was
like this uh this taffy pull of emotions
and people being angry or people being
supportive
but i think michael phelps calmed that
down a little bit
a lot because michael is saying it not
you know just some announcer so you guys
did great
explore thanks i i i agree with you dan
and i think you know in any sport we
turn to the
best of all time to help us understand
the sport right and
some cases they don't become the best tv
analysts right but we try to hire them
we put a microphone in their face and we
try to have them share their
uh experiences well michael was doing
that with the swimming stuff he said
some great stuff in swimming
but to do it in this avenue now lets
every other athlete know
in michael's words it's okay to not be
okay
and hopefully we'll get other folks to
realize that the mental health piece of
this
given the pressure and the exposure of
sports right now
is very real and something that we have
to have conversations about
look we have to get past the old days i
said i just played through pain
that's changed in sports a lot right
well this is another part of that just
play through the mental language the
mental
pain that might not be the case and we
have to be okay with that
if we're going to be okay with sharing
in the euphoria we get from when these
athletes do great things for the teams
that we love and care about
it's been eye-opening for me for sure
what can people look forward to tonight
with the coverage at uh
eight eastern yeah you'll see the
gymnastics with simone biles the track
and field uh
with a couple of terrific finals the 800
to 200 right benjamin in the 400
hurdles uh was was amazing with carsten
warhol uh
the other uh last night that would be
u.s time uh we'll have more live track
coming up
as the night goes on as well and some
diving it's the same week two olympic
potpourri of stuff
it's as you know uh swimming dominates
week one
track and field week two so it'll be a
heavy track and field as we go down the
last four or five days and
the us is uh is in pretty good shape
they have a variety of names that we're
learning and
a bunch of good stories so we'll uh
continue to share those next few days
here and then
the team stuff starts to wrap up with
hoops and all that the next few days as
well
you have been giving to us and i will
give back to you one more time satan
john luca paul yuka paul
the mother three two one
mike thanks for staying up and uh we'll
be watching tonight at eight eastern
always thanks dp everybody that's mike
tarico
nbc sports the olympic coverage
primetime host that's at 8
eastern